[Musique]
merci pour pour la seconde chance dans
les occasions de s'exprimer devant les
trêves mes camarades que je me sens que
je suis
dans ma femme dans ma deuxième famille
j'ai le sang
le léger et
j'ai eu d'autres des plans par la suite
mais reste mon diplôme de cap donc
négative pour moi je suis
c'est pas nouveau
je tiens ici à un exposé de chair qu'on
colle ce que je ne peux pas m'empêcher
de m'exclure navale et donc est ce que
je voudrais de ne pas rater cette
occasion aujourd'hui je passe le maximum
de messages désolé vous prenez
donc notre passé notre maximum de
messages avait dans mes frais c'est
l'objectif de cette séance n'est ce pas
donc je voudrais à celle des images de
créateurs congénères le cube de faire
sans protocole sans
effet de vitrine si vous voulez
quand le comité d'organisation a créé
pour organisme pour mériter cette cet
élément et monkey si tu peux raconter
mon histoire mon parcours
je suis dit ok bon sur les chausse
trappes mais vous n'êtes que j'ai une
occasion des gens de le faire à ma crise
et donc
certains bureaux ont déjà vu peut-être
une des vidéos ou plusieurs puisque je
suis quand même active sur
fonctionnaires et autres sauts sur le
lait sur le même temps
donc je me suis dit ok pour attirer
votre attention je voudrais
passer ses messages les deux autres
matches retour à travers des fictions
mon parcours mais
on essaie on a peu dans les synthèses
donc parcours en essayant de rassurer
parce que des nuls comme
comité de village olympique ne peut pas
résumer une vie de 38 ans aujourd'hui
j'ai 38 ans j'ai deux enfants je suis
marié c'est contre un que je ne me
définis le reste pour moi c'est un
détail c'est le parcours d'une vie et
c'est des hauts et des bas donc j'ai
comme lui fallait que je choisisse un
titre à ma présentation agi choisi que
ça peut être une citation mais je lis un
peu modifié la vie n'est pas lire la vie
notre vie n'est pas league est
simplement dans le sens pour dans les
boissons de vie léopold cap à l'est de
l'écossé de rue dans les boissons de vie
sains plus ne peut jamais être égal à 2
ni 13.3 y est né à saint jean et à 10 et
à moins 10
on contrôle en fait les deux
à puce paix de l'équation on les
contrôle d'accord c'est notre essence
pour ne pas dire que enfin la vie et les
simples où la vie il est difficile d'en
haut les gens mais il ya eu 2 83e elle
vole une troisième inconnue kohno on
aime c'est ce que j'appellerais de
vienne
et moi dans mon bateau
g us pour ne pas dire des milliers des
millions j'ai eu plusieurs second chance
chaque jour c'est une seconde chance
donc j'ai choisi un peu de raccordement
mon parcours
on ne sait non plus après ça d'accord
plusieurs la première étape c'est ce que
je suis aujourd'hui leurs actes parce
que je suis mais mon métier aujourd'hui
je suis directeur des services et des
opérations de recherche et développement
chez mathieu n'a pas cité le nom de
faire de la publicité
si nous société c'est une multinationale
de référence
multinationales françaises présentes au
maroc et la filiale marocaine
l'ex-responsable de l'afrique aussi donc
nous sommes l'antenne du groupe au
niveau de l'afrique mais aussi on est
présent en europe en amérique et que
c'était donc c'est vraiment une
société de référence et jusqu'à
aujourd'hui croyez quand je ne réalise
pas que je suis directeur des serres de
ces deux opérations de recherche et
développement de satisfaits giroud le
jeu jusqu'à redon
pourquoi
parce que en
en avril 2019
j'aime que tu as un chantier dans la vie
d'abord quand j'ai rejoint sur
ce chapitre c est la convention 2014 de
notre nation et il a pris ça au 2019
comment il a créé femmes en fait
j'ai préparé mon mon doctorat
j'ai eu mon docteur
et
je me suis dit ok
c'est une étape franchie qu'il faut que
je passe à autre chose
et je me cache pas je voyais un peu le
mot de
fond noir c'est pour ça jubile alliés
n'est pas aussi qu'elle se soit être la
force avec laquelle j'ai l'apparence de
5,2 d'être devant vous l'être humain il
est faible donc on passe pas d'héroïne
et faire remonter 8,19 j'ai eu et
j'ai pensé par l'église je me suis dit
ok générer un objectif c'est d'avoir mon
docteur
pour de longs bâtons
et je me dis qu'est-ce que je
cette indolence
et le glycol une expérience deux
sociétés trois sociétés dans le secteur
privé de 2014 à 2000 à 2010 j'ai aussi
expérimenté le secteur public et pour
j'ai appris beaucoup de choses
maintenant qu'est-ce que tu vas depuis
tuant quatre de la vie normale je suis
pour désigner tout
donc on discutant avec ma famille j'ai
visité on a décidé
[Musique]
de quitter droit
c'est une décision difficile ce qu'on
allait se séparer des proches
on allait j'ai préparé mon dossier pour
partir au canada
j'avais donc c'est vraiment un champ
terminé on passe de 38 ans - 31 -
français mais en tout cas c'est une
décision que n'a
pas nommément discuter et clichy et donc
on a prises j'ai préparé pendant une
année nos dossiers pour partir
vous l'équivalence des dom et vous
cherchez un emploi je trouvais trois
opportunités là bas et c'est tout un
barreau et à la fin
on était prêts j'ai démissionné de mon
poste qui est les ouïghours
l'une des zones citées manière
et j'étais prêt les valises 107 gt à
partir au canada j'ai tout organiser
enfin l'emploi le logement tout en
sachant que j'ai deux enfants et leur
mère qui ne suit pas c'est
la dernière il
pour ça j'ai dit aux fêtes de l'équation
est simple il y aura plus bmx la
dernière réunion que j'avais mon ex en
plus rien qui est l'université hérité au
ministère par rabat
et donc je vis à vis des fêtes comble
que je fasse un peu le transfert ciblex
que je gérais un projet national qui est
l'implémentation d'un système
d'information trajet
osaka et donc j'étais parti pour faire
cette réunion
et comme par hasard peut-être le hasard
ville surtout moi je dis le destin je
rencontre un ami un ami lequel j'ai pris
un café
une manière de sucre et de dire je me
moquais je la suis au chômage d'autres
contribuent mais et j'ai tous mes
papiers pour partir il me reste deux
mois trois mois pour partir le calme
mais alors pourquoi tu veux gagner
parce que franchement je
ne vois pas dans les
gg objectif
c'est donc pratiquement le respect je
dois je vois rien et surtout peu
dans la personne de pugnacité j'avais un
concile il est d'ailleurs la corrigerai
plus dans voyage la possibilité de
découvrir un peu le lot j'étais parti en
ligue 1 opposant lyon
en français et donc être l'étranger un
peu fade d'expérience étrangers malades
il je suis ok
pour les 40 ans de musique à
réguler elle
pense
donc je
suis content
on pourra tenter
ça marche
je reprends mon at-il
dit écoute
je te connais tu vas pas réussir à
concevoir ce je te dis que tu l'appareil
d'attentisme proposés
tu dirais précédentes on propose en
cause
et pour l'occasion fait c'était un ex
collègue au sein de la société où
j'avais travaillé de 2006 à la fin de
2006 2007 à 2012 à vendre et à la
domination allemande allait lui-même
donc il m'a dit juste autres opposants
je vais te manquer donc de lui m'a donné
en fait le rwanda n'est que sur alger
partie de l'avoir et
je suis d'accord ok on vous croit pas
que c'était une autre alléchant
financièrement rien de grave est un
officier national je suis ok parfait
gêner le projet d'une migration stade
white et puis j'ai discuté avec la
famille ou utiliser mon compte il dit ok
on va prendre une multitude des clients
en si jamais ça marchera en parle
j'ai rencontré la directrice et non aux
côtés d'un contrat
et le nombre de manches enfin en année
je reçois un appel d'un autre ami et
maintenant
j'en entends tu es en train de revenir
la société x tu lui as une gare du nord
menteur
projet et
nous le dit c'est hors de question
que tu culture loin de reims on
vient nous rejoindre je ne pousse toi et
tu va piloter
32 personnes avec deux équipes de
recherche et développement une équipe
basée à présent une équipe basée à
marrakech et tous les prix le taux
d'activité a fait avec tout ce que tu
veux comme avantage
sur les bienvenus demain je viens tu vas
voir une autre présidence et à toi à toi
de jouer
je crois franchement ces jeux c'est
hallucinant
merci merci je me dit chez nous toujours
nom de m est ce que le café était un
vrai destin est-ce que c'était une
seconde chance
pour moi oui c'est une énième seconde
chose et si vous voulez
moi
ça nous
h au plan d'eau les led la morale d'un
champ de séduction
et lâche m'adresse à mes chers frères
étudiants
scène revenu
elle leur a pu citer 2006 nous sommes
pour la réservation
le premier
concerne le deuxième but on sait que
vichy qui nous autres experts n'en veut
pas c'est sérieux les francas les ligues
d'accord pourquoi ce qui est deux autres
sourit jean et au centre et j'en ai des
ex connaît que j'ai
croisés dans les parents et longue vie à
l'eau le monde est petit donc si par
hasard j'en ai qui n'ont pas failli
pour et 7 aux relations cette
opportunité n'allait pas se présente
toutes les canalisations j'ai changé ma
vie aujourd'hui j'ai laissé compliment
pour projet de générations et entre
temps qui est promu au niveau de la
société je suis devenu aussi d'adhérer
je suis responsable de tactique et
projets et j'accompagne logique
d'entreprise au maroc les organismes
publics mais aussi dans notre chère pris
2 aubry on est en train à une entreprise
marocaine
un projet avec monique et un projet de
digitalisation de l'état c'est du moins
tout alu et
aujourd'hui j'ai cette responsabilité
j'ai l'honneur
en gros pour aider ne ferai pas
de seconde chance
la deuxième qui sort que je vais vous
raconter c'est parce que je les
rencontre mais pour très longtemps
5 minutes et ne resta but ok je les
observe et la vienne sont impliqués dans
le comté
s'est
sélectionné soir à lens avec avec avec
le prix correct a dit on par comac
qui mettra fin juillet je suis
originaire d'un petit point de perdu
nous avons deux de grands
cétacés
j'ai eu l'occasion de lui raconter mon
histoire
depuis mon optique en france
très touché mon souci c'était d'excès
dans l'île à son lancement et
de réussir ma vie
dans son ensemble
j'ai eu l'occasion la suisse laisse
gérer contrôler 6 3
[Musique]
assez joigny et je ne dis pas comme ça
pour jeter les frères l'un cg c'est une
des meilleures écoles 10 au
[Applaudissements]
début de ma propre expérience et c'est
mon opinion
gigi
oeri résidait
et
a gagné pour sa victoire à dijon
en jean à gagner et
je m'amuse
[Musique]
le cg
les rires j'avais beaucoup de problèmes
parler de l'amour ou chipchura et jamais
je
viendrai mon père était décédé ma mère
c'est une fois pourquoi y ait zéro je
suis fier et
je suis jolie
protéger
le reste il viendra je partis différents
salue le plan dès la première année
quand quelqu'un qui cherche vraiment à
faire
et c'est toujours en tête c'est il faut
que j'ai fait
kimmons pour et deux contre un et 2 5 de
chuck qu'il voulait je voulais donc j'ai
fait les
deux projets
de le dire et de lui faire de zèle de la
conscience j'étais fier
moi je vais pas m'arrêter en dessous
donc j'ai dit
j'ai une famille a soutenu m mail mes
petits frères petite soeur j'avais une
famille chez obligés d'intégrer de
l'orgie de travail j'ai travaillé ma
première expérience la deuxième
expérience
2014 je suis
sidéré religieuses de sa
carrière une voiture fait une erreur
j'ai eu une première petite fille est
aujourd'hui temps ça fait chier
j'ai encore de glaire la chute les deux
îles jamais ne lui une chute c'est le
moment moi je le vois comme ça parce que
qu'elle écrit
7% tu ne la lui et grâce à des conseils
pratiques
sauvant des
machines
à jour on
énergie c'est le conte et musique
qu'est ce que j'ai je prépare ce qui n'a
pas plu
il fut créé par le dock et ans je
voulais continuer jusqu'aux monts et
lacs est né à chalon dont la connerie
est d'abord tenté de faire
je voulais
donc j'ai
si je reste dans le privé j'étais
responsable du coin organisation au sein
de la première aussi
et je n'avais pas de temps c'est
vraiment et des classes très chargées je
m'occupe pas je te faire un master par
la sphère de recherche je préfère
investir en europe mais c'est pas ça ce
que je donc je me suis dit il faut que
tu changes 2010 et c'est là où est venue
l'idée de changer
et c'est délicieux
courageuse à prendre
je vous le dis parce que je suis si je
ne continue musique buts et intégrer un
peu
je puisse continuer à l'aise mais j'ai
vu il fallait que je développe mon
salaire de 70 pouces 1
35 je les considérais comme une bourse
pour que je dise qu'on diminue j'ai
préparé - master et le doctorat
hommes tapera
deux ans au masters et deux en aiguille
pour le dr et j'ai soutenu que notre vie
vous vouliez en fait que
croyez vous
croyez en dieu nous mes neveux leccia
que c'est la famille quand vous arrivez
au mas faut rebondir c'est ça
l'essentiel et c'est sympa ce qui fait
que la vie n'est pas ligne aile et que
des milliers de seconde chance on
s'entend mais chaque chose et chaque
rapidement soit je suis désolé que des
bons d
achat lié
à des coûts toujours la présence
[Applaudissements]
j'aurais également à partager mais je
suis très très très envie d'être à
nouveau et je suis à votre disposition
je suis là pour vous et je savais que
vous ayez
témoin nous on accuse
créole écrit hier entre disposition
[Musique]